good evening everyone and welcome to the
European Parliament here in Strasbourg
my name is Maria and Parliament approved
today the new rules about energy
performance of buildings which aim to
make sure that new and system buildings
um will generate less energy and will
generate fewer greenhouse gas emissions
to talk about it I am joined by Mr Karen
Koff the member responsible of this
legislation at the European Parliament
so welcome Mr thank you very much yeah
and of course congrats for the positive
vote today but before we start we are
Live on YouTube LinkedIn and Facebook so
please you can leave your comments and
questions in the chat and I'll try to to
put as many as possible to my guests in
the next half an hour or so
so now we'll we will go straight into it
first Mr cuff can you tell us what the
links are between buildings and climate
change good question
um the links are really clear
we know that buildings consume a lot of
energy about 40 percent of the energy in
Europe is consumed within buildings uh
and because of this they also are
responsible uh for a huge amount of our
greenhouse gas emissions about 36 so
over one third of our greenhouse gas
emissions in Europe are directly or
indirectly coming uh from buildings so
if we can reduce the emissions from
buildings we're well on our way to
tackling our climate goals
um a lot of people don't know this they
think oh um agriculture transport but
actually buildings and the construction
of buildings users and a lot of energy
and creates a lot of emissions the good
news about all of this is we can do
something about it we can insulate our
homes we can put PV panels photovoltaic
panels on the roofs we can go for new
technologies like heat pumps if we do
all of this we save money and we Save
the Planet so from what you are saying
the revision of this legislation will be
key to um to reducing emissions what are
the most important elements yeah I mean
it's absolutely key and the long title
of the law it's the energy performance
of buildings directive that's a bit of a
mouthful particularly the technical name
it's the recast of the energy
performance buildings directive forget
about the name this is about taking the
buildings that we're in that we live in
that we work in and improving their
energy performance they consume massive
amounts of gas of oil of electricity and
sometimes it's as easy as just
insulation you know the way estate
agents talk about location location for
buildings insulation insulation
insulation but it's not just insulation
we also need new technologies and if we
do this if we upgrade our buildings if
we have a renovation wave it absolutely
saves money of course it's not cheap it
takes real money to do this but an
investment in renovation it has a
payback time it will reduce the
emissions it'll reduce your bills and
this winter so many Europeans saw
sky-high energy bills and we want to
help people move away from that there's
money available from Europe there's
money available from uh from various
European Union instruments and we think
we can do this and make a real
difference in improving the quality of
people's lives indeed many Europeans are
struggling this year with the cost of
heat in their homes but could you
elaborate more specifically how do you
how do the new rules aim to support this
affected people the the kernel or the
essence of this new law is something
called minimum energy performance
standards and this is about a letter
between a and g indicating what energy
assumption the building you're in has a
really high performance building is an A
A really poor performing building is a g
and we want to move buildings up through
these scales you know these days if you
buy a washing machine or even a light
bulb it'll have this color-coded letter
on the side of it and obviously if we
can we try and go for a c a b or an A
and it's exactly the same for buildings
a lot of countries around Europe already
have this color-coded system and in fact
for new buildings a lot of countries
insist that you get to a b or an A but
now we're saying look it's not just
about the new buildings we need to
improve the standard there but we also
need to take all the other buildings and
you know eighty percent of the buildings
that are out there today will still be
there in the year 2050. so it's really
important it's crucial that we tackle
these buildings and gradually over time
do these deep energy retrofits you you
don't have to do it all today or
tomorrow you can do it in stages but
we're saying look let's start on the
journey the a rating that's where we
want to be by 2050 you can't do that
overnight it costs a lot of money but
let's get to an E by 2030. I mean this
isn't exactly a breath next speed it's
Movement we want to get to an E by 2030
a d by 2033 for residential buildings
and gradually over time we nudge or move
everything further up the scale and to
me that's really important so step by
step then what about all protected
buildings are there special routes for
the renovation yeah yeah I mean we have
to have exemptions if we if we said that
every single building had to be upgraded
what would we do would we take the
Coliseum clearly not so Heritage
buildings we don't have to do we don't
have to do Renovations we say they're
out of scope they're not affected by by
the uh by the law but actually a lot of
older buildings you can do lots you can
put in secondary glazing you can put
insulation in the Attic you can even in
some cases put in PV panels they don't
have to be right there
visible from everywhere but maybe you
can put them in the roof where they're
hidden so there's a lot you can do with
an older building so we're saying that
the Heritage buildings are out of scope
and actually a lot of other buildings
Holiday Homes we're not telling you to
you know to put treble glazing into a
holiday home that maybe you're in for
one month a year uh small buildings are
exempt temporary buildings are exempt so
we're trying to be fair and we're trying
to be flexible and to me this is the
essence of the new law okay so there are
a few exemptions that are reasonable
yeah and in fact not only the exemptions
that I've mentioned but we're also
saying to countries look
you can make a list of maybe 20 22 of
the buildings and say look we're not
going to touch these for the moment we
might come back to it later on but we
don't want you to tackle everything so
that again gives that flexibility so
we're not we don't have a rigid European
rule for every building in every member
State yeah it was
thinking of course there are disparities
among new country since there is also
like different climates depending on the
country so as a member responsible for
this legislation how do you tackle these
these parties and they assembalance well
we don't we don't say one site one size
suits all and clearly what you need to
do to a building in Northern Finland is
very different from a building in
Portugal in Finland you might already
have double glazing and you might put in
troubled lazy in Portugal you might
decide look the windows are fine we'll
just put photovoltaic panels on the roof
so we can recharge our vehicle outside
and save on the energy bills there so we
divide Europe into different climate
zones Nordic Mediterranean Oceanic uh
central European uh and you can even do
that within a country so for maybe
Sweden or Italy typically Alpine in the
North Mediterranean in the Deep South
different standards for for what you
what you do there here and that's an
important thing as well and also
you have different types of buildings in
different countries in Central Europe
you have a lot of tower blocks apartment
buildings that are quite tall with
District heating systems whereas in
Western Europe in my own country of
Ireland you have a lot of one-off
housing so maybe you do wrap around
insulation there or maybe in Hungary you
upgrade the the
um the district heating scheme and get
it to run on uh biomass instead of oil
or coal so every every country will have
a different will have a different
approach also and this is really
important we have this scale I talked
about the color-coded the rainbow scale
from a being green to G bean I think
orange but
each country has a different G rating
and we're saying for each country G will
be the lowest 15 the worst performing
buildings in that country and that's
going to be really different different
in Denmark to Bulgaria so really we're
saying each country will play a part but
we don't want people to sort of do
what's impossible we want these
countries to take the worst performing
buildings and to improve them by 2030
but you're not going to have to do crazy
stuff that you don't have the capacity
you don't have the workforce or you
don't have the skills in place
so following with the climate how can we
adapt our buildings to extreme weather
events such as heat waves or flats you
know it's a it's it's a good point and
uh tragically uh two years ago hundreds
of people lost their hundreds of people
lost their lives in floods with extreme
weather in Belgium and Germany but also
heat waves can be devastating
particularly for older people
and actually the solution for both
extreme cold and extreme heat is often
insulation so to wrap around the
building and protect the people inside
from the extremes of weather
and sometimes
um you can tackle a few different issues
both reducing the greenhouse gas
emissions but sometimes you want to do
seismic improvements so that buildings
are safer from earthquakes you might
also want to ensure that you protect
people from flooding or that you allow
greater access for people with
disabilities wheelchair access so
sometimes you can do works that not only
deliver for climate but that also
deliver for accessibility for seismic
protection or for disabled access
but how can we help how can the European
Union help those who lack the financial
capacity to for example cool their
houses their homes in the summer really
good question uh and thankfully uh
there's a lot of different uh funding
available directly from European funding
the recovery and resilience funding
which is the after covert recovery money
lots of this can be used to upgrade
buildings I think Italy has 15 billion
Euro available so that would provide a
lot of insulation some countries can
draw down more of this than others but
there's a lot of money from that fund
but you can also use structural funds
you can use the invest EU money you can
use the European social fund even the
just transition funds are available to
not just upgrade buildings but to
retrain people so let's say you were a
coal miner you want to retrain and you
can retrain to become a building
retrofitter so it'll create jobs and
that's what I love about this file it's
not just about climate it's about
Comfort it's about employment it's about
um
tackling lots of different issues so
those are the direct for some of the
direct funds there's others uh that I
just don't have in my head at the moment
but there's about six different funds
and then there's financial institutions
in Europe the European Investment Bank
the European Central Bank interestingly
the European Central Bank they said we
want this file to go through not very
often the ECB starts talking about laws
that we're making here in Strasbourg in
the European Parliament but they did
they said we want this air file to go
through and then of course the European
Investment Bank they're rebranding to
become the European climate bank and a
lot of their money is already going to
uh to building upgrades in my own city
of Dublin hundreds of millions of Euro
are available to local Authority housing
to social housing to provide an upgrade
so it's there's money there we need more
money but I think once the law is passed
more money will flow perfect
so you you have just mentioned that the
newly the new rules will also create new
jobs but that's the EU have the
Necessary Technology and also skills
labor to carry out those Renovations and
modernization yeah
um we do we have a lot of the skills but
we need more uh and particularly with uh
the covert pandemic there's been supply
chain shortages I mean whoever thought
one ship stuck in the middle of the Suez
Canal would cause a log Jam creating
huge problems around the world but it
did and obviously with lockdowns uh the
the manufacturers of Building Products
had to slow down so there is actually
um a have been supply chain shortages
but we're coming over them or overcoming
them so shipping costs have come down
and I think we'll see the cost of these
Building Products come down as well but
then of course we at War we've had war
in Ukraine so that's another added
challenge in the whole uh discussion of
of of what's available again I think
this is a temporary issue I hope and
pray it's a temporary issue but I think
particularly when this directive kicks
in and a lot of the stuff kicks in 2030
2033 by then I think we'll be ramping up
at the con the production of Building
Products which is good
but you also you spoke about the the
skills issue and actually we do need to
upskill our construction workers and
that includes the professionals The
Architects the surveyors the engineers
but also the Crafts People the
installers because the the man or woman
who puts in a central heating system and
they're used to gas boilers they do have
to retrain to do heat pumps the
certification can be different but it's
not rocket science I mean you cannot
upgrade within a matter of weeks for
these new technologies for solar panels
so I think yep we need to train the
trainers
provide the skills but I think we get
over this relatively quickly and we move
on into really providing good jobs
sustainable jobs not just for the next
two years or three years but all the way
to 2050 and I think that will reduce the
boom and bust nature of construction
Cycles in Europe counter cyclical is
what we call it so it dampens down the
Peaks and provides real jobs within the
troughs and I think over time it's a
real positive
Russians Russia's illegal invasion of
Ukraine has highlighted importance of
reducing dependence on energy Imports
will the new rules help the EU to become
more energy independent oh it will and I
think not only is this good for climate
it improves our energy Security in
Europe we often talk about Energy
Efficiency has been the the real
low-hanging fruit in in climate action
but in a sense it absolutely reduces our
energy needs we talk about talk about
negawatts rather than megawatts so the
negative energy by that I mean the more
we insulate our homes homes the less
energy we need coming from places like
Russia and it's not just Russia it's the
Middle East where we're dealing with
countries that aren't exactly Paragons
of democracy so I think improving the
European Union's energy dependence
Independence is a really good thing and
that will that will accelerate as the
years go by
where would you answer to those who say
that right now due to interest rates
Rising is not a good time to make people
carry out those building renovations
I guess there's there's never a perfect
time to do this when the economy is
booming it's hard to find the workers
when the economy is in recession
we wonder where the money is but I think
actually historically interest rates are
still relatively low and the eib the
European Investment Bank it's lending
money to governments at negative
interest rates so that's cheap money and
I think now is a good time to draw down
this money and you know I think one of
the lessons from the global financial
crisis from 15 years ago was we
shouldn't just be stuck in the
headlights when there's a problem and I
think really
the last few years have been about the
Perma crisis covered then Ukraine then
really high energy costs I think we've
got to just be calm and start putting in
place the investment that's needed and I
think this will be one of the legs of
the European economy going forward for
the next uh 30 years and to me climate
action it's about possibilities and
opportunities and I see it across the
board in agriculture in transport in
energy in construction we really have
the possibility for creating good jobs
for the future and you know it's it's
not all perfect there will be winners
and losers there are Sunrise Industries
under our Sunset Industries and you know
people are concerned about ending the
production of the internal combustion
engine but rest assured there's going to
be lots of jobs in improving our
buildings over the next 20 or 30 years
so I I think it will be a positive and
there's also
um there's also possibilities for
looking at the links between buildings
and transport very simply you build a
home you put solar panels on the roof
those solar panels can provide the power
for your vehicle for your car or your
e-bike or your scooter so a lot of your
Mobility needs the energy for that can
be met by your home and to me that's
this virtuous circle which can be a real
benefit to everyone so indeed all these
sectors are interconnected
um Parliament approved the recast of the
legislation today but what are the next
steps yeah
this is I guess the second last stage
um we we got agreement between the
Shadows then agreement from the energy
committee today here in Strasbourg we
got agreement from the parliament it now
goes on to what we call a trialogue and
this is when the different institutions
in Europe talk to each other so the
European commission the Council of
ministers and the Parliament we sit down
in a trial log because there's three
legs to it and we hammer out a deal and
this is the famous you know meetings
that can go on until six o'clock in the
morning and really
the parliament is ambitious the
commission is relatively ambitious the
council less so so hammering out a deal
is what we have to do and I'm hoping we
can do this over the next three months
under the rotating presidency under the
Swedish presidency uh actually at the
moment so I will lead the discussion for
the parliament I'll have the shadows in
other words the representatives of the
other political groups in the room
helping me out in this but ultimately we
want to strike a deal and if we do then
the law the the directive The Proposal
becomes law and it's up to the member
states to deliver that doesn't happen
overnight they'll have to produce
National Building renovation plans but
slowly but surely over the years ahead
sometimes in a year sometimes five years
sometimes Ten Years you'll see this
investment flow you'll see the
Improvement you'll see people living and
working in more comfortable buildings
and I think this has got to be good news
for Europe and what do you see as the
big um like the big challenges when
negotiating with the national
governments
I think some countries were not as
ambitious as the parliament in fact some
countries said this is a crazy file we
don't want to see it go through some
countries weaponized the file they said
uh this this is Europe telling you what
to do with your home you'll be evicted
if you don't do it and nothing could be
further from the truth uh so but it will
be difficult to deal with the council uh
you know 27 member states it's like a
teacher with a class you're trying to
say
let's work together in this you're
saying to the unruly child
gotta behave yourself I'm not saying
that you you can control everything but
we've got to bring everybody with us and
sometimes that means that the ambition
goes down a bit and that's the nature of
how this how things work in the European
Parliament you go in with your head high
saying we want everything to be an a
rating tomorrow and then you crawl from
the record six months later and you say
well we got some of what we wanted we
didn't get everything and it's hard to
know where things will go but it may be
that the ambition comes down a little
bit from what we'd like to see here in
the parliament itself now you are still
positive about the final outcome you
know to be in politics you have to be
optimistic and I I always go in saying
it's going to be great but I think it
will be good I I think it really is a
win-win I'm positive so I'm going
through some of the comments from our
followers and there are users who are
saying that they want to make their
buildings more climate friendly by using
solar panels but they they are saying
that this is quite expensive as well so
you talk about the funding before but
will they be able to access any
financial support to obtain this kind of
uh yeah some some countries already have
um have supports for installing solar
panels and in fact there's a under the
renewable energy directive if you
produce energy on your roof if you
produce electricity you have a right to
be paid if you feed it back into the
grid so some countries are good at doing
that others it's taking a bit of time
but there can be a payback sometimes
it's as little as seven years in fact
when the energy prices spiked during the
early part of this winter the payback
period was was very short but look there
won't be an immediate payback for
everybody sometimes it will take a
decade to to get a payback from the from
the technologies that you use but in
some instances you can simply use the
energy to feed into your vehicle into
your car and I I have a friend and he
he's driving 15 000 kilometers a year
from the energy he gets from the solar
panels on this roof okay so also for our
viewers who are watching us today what
can we do on our daily basis to cut
energy consumption because this is
actually what Energy Efficiency is um
yeah it's all about sometimes it seems a
little bit daunting of oh my gosh I have
to replace all my windows but you don't
there's lots of little things that you
can do turning off radiators in a room
that you're not using is a real simple
step that we've done at home and it
saved us a lot of energy this winter
putting in these valves on the radiators
most modern houses have them but these
thermostatic radio
major evolves they essentially make sure
that you don't put too much heat into a
room that you're not using or raising
the temperature to too high the TVR
valves are great they cost maybe 20 30
40 Euro each but they can pay for
themselves in one heating season
looking at the drafts in your house so
making sure that you don't leave windows
open putting in a little bit of weather
stripping we call it in English around
your doors that are letting air in and
out all of these changes can be measured
in tens or maybe a few hundred Euro and
they can pay for themselves in a heating
season the bigger Investments the new
windows uh the new heating system
replacing a gas boiler with a heat pump
that can cost 10 000 Euro but can also
pay for itself over a number of years I
mean what I say to people is a really
significant upgrade for your home it can
be the price of a new car but it can
also save you a lot of money over a
10-year period And even between the huge
big deeper deep retrofit and a little
bit of of checking out the drafts or
turning down the radiators insulation in
your attic or in your apartment block
that can be a big saving as well so
everything from 10 euro to 10 000 Euro
there's a lot of things we can do in
between and I think that's something for
households to think about
um and one of the nice things I like
about this directive is there's a lot of
people living in energy poverty in
Europe because they're tenants they're
not they're they're unable to do the
upgrade of their building but it puts
pressure on the landlord to to to do
work because the tenant pays the bills
and often the landlord says I'm fine I
don't need to do anything but this this
directive it will put pressure on the
landlord to do cost optimal renovations
to do upgrades that will save money for
the tenant and that's really where we
want to see action as well as everywhere
there won't be it won't be like the
tenants doing taking care of the
renovations but the landlords right
right
okay so Mr government like my final
question you are anarchitected by
profession have you noticed that change
of mindset in the building industry
during the past years
I I have and I think you know every 10
years you get a wave of enthusiasm for
green issues and we saw that 10 years
ago
and it it faded away but I think this
time it's different uh I think we've
seen these crazy extreme weather events
here in Europe uh in my own city of
Dublin we saw uh the maximum temperature
ever recorded last summer we saw crazy
weather in in Brussels and around Europe
even last summer so I do think it's
different and I think construction
professionals are seeing that there's a
good business case for investing in this
five years ago ten years ago my fellow
Architects said oh yeah energy that's
all very well but I'm an artist I create
beautiful spaces now they're a little
bit less reluctant to say that they're
saying actually we need to do something
and that to me is a really positive step
people know we have to invest in this we
have to make a change and people are
doing this and I think people are
benefiting and it's not just about
saving money in your pocket but it's
about saving the planet as well
so thanks a lot for your time today and
best of luck with the negotiations with
the EU countries and thank you to all of
you for tuning in don't forget to come
back to our social media accounts if you
want to find out more about what's going
on in the at the European Parliament
this week so yeah Mr cuff thanks again
thank you and have a lovely evening
thanks very much thank you